[Music]
welcome to the program there's been more
fighting in the last pocket of
anti-taliban resistance in afghanistan's
panchayat valley with both sides
claiming advances the national
resistance front made up of militias and
former afghan security force members
it's the last group to hold out against
taliban rule but the taliban says the
entire country is now under its control
charles stratford joins me now from
kabul morning charles conflicting
stories really from both sides as to who
has the upper hand
that's right sahil we saw last night
i suppose it was about half an hour 40
minutes of celebratory gunfire in kabul
it was very loud i mean you could
actually say that it was a a louder and
longer celebration than we saw once the
u.s troops finally left
and these were on the back of reports
similarly by taliban commanders unnamed
three of them we understand from that
area panchayat valley that were saying
that the taliban had full control of the
valley since then
those reports have been heavily refuted
we understand that there is ongoing
fighting this is a large area it is
heavily defended by the nrf by these
opposition forces
we understand that the taliban have
surrounded the area we've known that
certainly according to the taliban for
the last few days but it was late last
night when video was leaked out um
from the valley and reportedly
sent to a a journalist with the bbc um
and that video shows uh the former
uh president sorry former vice president
of afghanistan i'm rule lasalle sitting
in a room with books behind him saying
today is the third of september and
these reports about the panshir valley
having fallen are completely baseless a
total lie he said that the resistance
would continue
and saying that he was very much a
sconce in the valley itself
it's very difficult to get any solid
information from inside the valley
because communications has been blocked
by the taliban
we were close to the entrance around
about this time yesterday morning the
fighting was was heavy when we arrived
and we spoke to a lot of civilians a lot
of terrified civilians in that area and
this is our report
smoke rises over the town of gulbahar
the entrance to the panchir valley in
northeast afghanistan
neither the soviets during the 1980s war
nor the taliban have ever managed to
control this mountainous region around
100 kilometers north of kabul
a shell lands nearby
taliban fighters ready their weapons
men in this village say they have driven
their wives and children to safety they
are angry and scared
the americans betrayed us president
ghani betrayed us too
you left us under the cannons and tanks
and we can't stop either side fighting
how much can they kill their brothers
how much can they kill their fellow
afghans they have to stop fighting
the taliban drive american military
vehicles and pick up trucks taking
fighters to and from the front line
thousands of men like these across
afghanistan have known little else but
conflict and war all their lives
the fighting started three days ago now
we've taken a lot of areas up there by
the antenna we have no issue with the
civilians we are here to defend their
rights people are staying in their homes
the national resistance front of
afghanistan or nrf is believed to be
several thousand strong and made up of
mainly ethnic tajik fighters and former
afghan army soldiers the group is led by
this man ahmad masood
he's british military academy trained
and the son of ahmad shah masoud who
fought against the soviets and the
taliban and was assassinated by al-qaeda
two days before the 9 11 attacks in
2001.
ahmed massoud is demanding the taliban
form an inclusive government which
guarantees the rights of all
afghanistan's ethnic minorities
including ethnic tajics who make up
around a quarter of the country's
population
the fighting started after two weeks of
negotiations with the taliban collapsed
we have a lot of equipment with
ourselves we will defend from our willy
from our territory until we have one
blood of one drop of blood in our body
so we will resist until we martial in
here
taliban fighters edge up a slope along
tracks they say are heavily mined
as we were getting ready to go live
another shell landed close by
the taliban has blocked phone networks
in the valley there are growing fears
about the estimated 150 000 people
living inside and many in taliban
controlled areas around gulbahar
the big concern is that massoud's forces
are coming round on the mountain ridges
are trying to surround this area in
order to isolate gulbahar
we left in gulbahar but now we are
living
today i came from kabul to collect our
belongings
i already took my family out the
fighting is ongoing there are shells
hitting people's homes both sides are
shelling
afghan families flee for their lives in
one of the last pockets of resistance to
taliban rule
so there are also reports last night uh
from taliban um
taliban commanders that a town called
biryan which is just north of the panchi
valley basically on the border of that
the next northern state had been taken
by the taliban even that is impossible
to concern as i say this area is
incredibly isolated very difficult to
get to and certainly the taliban are
telling us that all areas around it a
lot of them are heavily mined
what's got to be stressed though is that
the nrf
this group that are fighting the taliban
in the valley are heavily armed
we understand that they've been
stockpiling weapons some people are
saying for actually decades weapons
never stopped flowing into their um
after the end of the war with the soviet
union
so we know they're heavily armed uh we
understand they they could have up to
some reports of up to 10 000 fighters
but it's very difficult to get supplies
in so there are huge concerns now for
the as i say around 150 000 people
living in there uh we understand the
majority of them tagics um and also on a
political level as well it's very
interesting because people are saying
that although we've been waiting for
this government to be announced the
formation of a new taliban government
many people here are saying there's no
way that a government can be announced
if if it's to be inclusive like the
taliban are promised it will be when
they're fighting what effectively is
another war
in the panshir valley against a very
significant ethnic minority tajiks are
about a quarter of the population of
this country
so this this problem this conflict has
huge ramifications uh for a vast amount
of civilians caught in the middle um and
obviously the the political stability
of this country and the taliban's
efforts to to as they say
start again
charles trafford there for us in kabul
thanks for the update charles
now u.s secretary of state anthony
blinken says he'll travel to qatar and
germany to visit diplomats and troops as
well as well as afghans evacuated from
kabul now he says the taliban must
honour its commitments if it wants
relief from sanctions
we have worked intensely across the
international community to set a very
clear international expectation
of what the world is looking for from
the taliban when it comes to freedom of
travel now enshrined in among other
things the u.n security council
resolution
that by the way is
significant in a number of ways one of
which is that as you know
the taliban among other things is
seeking sanctions relief uh un sanctions
uh it is seeking
the ability for its leaders to travel
freely which again under u.n sanctions
they currently cannot do absent an
exemption
and um
if a taliban led government is in
violation of this latest security
council resolution on freedom of travel
it'll be it's pretty hard to see how
they would get for example that kind of
relief
in other news the united states
government could release some classified